-Julianne,
we've known each other --
I've known you for years.
You've been a famous actress
for many years,
but you used to have
an entirely different career.
You used to be a lawyer.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's right,
back in the '90s, yeah.
-Yeah, and a lot of people
don't know this,
but I was a lawyer, as well.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-And we actually worked
at the same law firm
before breaking
into entertainment.
-Well, yeah, it's kind of --
It's where we made our acting
debuts, you know, in a way.
Do you remember -- remember
those commercials we'd shoot?
-I don't.
-No?
-No.
-Think about it.
-Of course I remember them.
Are you kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
It was the first time being
on camera for both of us.
So to keep
our line readings fresh,
we wouldn't see the lines
until while we were shooting.
We just read them
off the cue cards.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-And you could really tell
that we didn't rehearse.
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, guess what.
I actually found
one of our old commercials.
-[ Gasps ]
No.
-So, here for
the first time in decades,
one of our ads for the law
offices of Moore & Fallon.
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The law offices of
Moore & Fallon
will fight for you to get you
the help you deserve.
♪♪
-At Moore & Fallon...
[ Laughter ]
...we'll take on your case
and make sure you win.
Fighting a speeding ticket?
No problem.
Just don't pay it.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I did.
And all that happened
was that I went to jail.
[ Laughter ]
[ Gavel bangs ]
-Hey, you want to sue
the Cheesecake Factory?
We'll sue the Cheesecake Factory
for $20 million.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause last time I checked,
that place isn't a factory.
It's a restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
Get it together, idiots.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Have you or a loved one
suffered after being bitten
by Maroon 5 singer Adam Levine?
[ Laughter ]
How did that even happen?
Why would he bite you?
I need --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-If you need legal help,
log on to our website now
at www.mooreandfallon.com/
newcases/formsnewemail.com
dot gov dot law
4799999999999
dot law.
[ Laughter ]
-Have you ever been injured?
-Do you need help?
-What's the deal with air--
airline food?
[ Laughter ]
-Why do we park in the driveway
but drive in the parkway?
-We have so many questions, but
we don't know how Google works.
-It's conf--
It's confusing!
[ Laughter ]
-My parents thought
I was gonna be a twin.
[ Laughter ]
And it turns out I was just
a super chubby baby.
[ Gavel bangs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Me big lawyer.
Me make big-time money.
Me throw money in trash.
[ Laughter ]
Trash can rich now.
I make trash can money.
[ Laughter ]
-Remember that lady who spilled
McDonald's coffee on herself
and then got a bunch of money
for it?
We were the lawyers
for McDonald's.
Not really.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wha--
[ Laughter ]
-I'm a little bit country.
-And I'm a little bit
rock 'n' roll.
-Which is why
we wrote this jingle.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
[ Laughing ]
-♪ Moore and Fallon ♪
♪ Moore and Fallon ♪
♪ We charge
a hundred bucks an hour ♪
♪ But we only accept Bitcoin ♪
-When was this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The law offices
of Moore & Fallon.
Call now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. We --
-Yeah.
I --
-We instantly went bankrupt.
-I can't believe it.
-Also that we knew
what Bitcoin was in the '90s.
-I know.
-And Google.
-My thanks to Julianne Moore.